I reject nation I'm Greg Alba I'm John
Humphrey we're gonna watch the trailer
numero dos for Pet Sematary I feel like
the glasses make my nose look bigger ooh
what do you think comment below people
tell Greg about his physical appearance
that's gonna go why won't I edit that
out of the video no no we're about to
watch this trailer and then talk a
little bit about it but before that I
wanted to say thank you muchos Gracias
to everyone who has followed us on all
of our patreon crap over there we do
weekly q and A's that's fun [ __ ] for you
kids and also we do TV show stream
alongs for shows like my hero academia
attack on titan i just started up one
punch man Full Metal Alchemist
Brotherhood supernatural Gotham think
Riverdale we'll find out I mean John is
is on the current season right now and
now for several shows on our patreon
page weird out doing those you know that
fair use 10-minute reaction highlights
with footage included for shows like
supernatural my hero academia started
from the beginning with one punch man
and Wayne follow us on our patreon page
at seminary
today I'll just go there they're
charming a little a little work really
Emily blue please just a real passion
remember what seems scary this not oh
okay it's not a fire story there was a
local driving home before they split
they feared that place there's something
out there
stream using the days whoa yeah I was
dead Church it brings things back
Oh
oh nothing like a good Achilles heel
slice that's what I meant to make you
wake up in the morning gross yeah I'm
still not 100% sold in this movie I have
a strong feeling that it'll be better
than most but there's also that feeling
in me that's like is it the trailer it's
just really cool because some of the
last Pet Sematary trailer when things
started kicking into high gear and like
the horror stuff that's what I'm like
yeah but then it's the stuff leading up
to it that I'm just not as invested in
it so getting cold over there like in
that when he's first showing him I guess
what Pet Sematary is yeah that sequence
where everything is there in the woods
yes late at night and it looks all it
looks like all the trees are dead damn
look at them digital enhancements and
yeah cool it's spooky but it does feel
like very digitally enhanced I'm not a
big fan of it you know horror movie
dialogue yeah yeah it's not a scary
place even though you know people might
think it's scary it's not scary even
those really gonna be really scary
normal it's normal just like dying yeah
yeah and I was way too comfort no
and I hope that that's just like a
truncated trailer like I do hope this
movie takes time for the characters and
stuff like that because the original one
I kind of remember doing that anyway
this trailer definitely seems to cover a
lot of ground in terms of the story and
what happens because the first one I
don't think really hinted at all at the
turn with the daughter and all that
stuff which in the original movie yeah
son the concept of Pet Sematary is a
little goofy
yeah that's an concepts and the first
one seemed the the that first movie
seemed to be aware that this is a little
bit of a goofy concept yeah and this one
is going this is the full-blown serious
version oh yeah super you bury something
it comes back to life yeah yeah what I
mean I'm kind of interested by that
approach just because I feel like I've
said this before but this could be an
opportunity for them to do something
kind of like the crazies did where it's
like the original one had a certain
amount of things that it does get right
and it had a lot of you know the
potential there but there are certain
things that have an aged very well and
so I'm hoping that yes can be one of
those remakes that really delivers on
some of the little elements that didn't
necessarily get nailed the first time I
do have faith in this movie I don't know
why there's that worry that I also have
though Oh word - especially with horror
movies especially with well shot horror
movies a lot of times you get like a
good-looking horror movie with awesome
cinematography and all those elements
included and then you put some like
creepy editing and sound design music
and string music on a trailer and then
you go wow this looks freakin awesome
then you watch the movie that's my
concerns because I feel like with
well-shot big-budget horror movies it's
usually easier to manipulate a trailer
to make it look like a good movie
because right now with both trailers and
especially this one
my feeling is man this looks cool like
all that body horst oh yeah that was
awesome man that I was like super freaky
creepy
you know it's like it looks like it will
have someone jump scares and you know
excuses for kids with creepy masks you
know yeah but overall I mean I like the
vibe that they're going there and I like
a lot of the imagery I like that it
feels very remote and very kind of
naturalistic especially with these
daytime shots to where you know it
really does feel like you're in a
secluded rural area which is just a nice
I don't know change of pace in a sense
to me
and also with Jason Clark having the you
know his watery eyes and Clark
deteriorating I like character
performances where people are
deteriorating a lot I forgot about but
what the consummate daughter died with
and that shot happened and you cut to
his tear that's called a great cut
that's a great inspired moment from this
trailer yeah not that I want every movie
that they're trying to nail it on the
second go around to take all the notes
from the movie it
one thing that it got down pretty well
for a Stephen King adaptation was
finding the levity and the humor about
its material and meshing that in here
the thing with the trailers those chosen
I had that that yeah
and then you watch the movie you're like
I feel like a lot of humor in here yeah
that makes the horror even more
effective and that's a very different
film different directors just because
it's a Stephen King annotation doesn't
mean you should do the same thing I'm
kind of hoping that they find some humor
about this I can try I can't let my mind
completely escape into well the concept
is a little silly yeah Billy you should
have a little bit of humor about it but
there were some like creepy scary
moments I liked that little nugget of
when a mother sees her daughter back hug
her hug her back of your daughter like
that's that dry delivery of what have I
done you know so I'm solving the serious
moment so I'm wondering if that might
lend itself to a slightly kinda dull
experience when there's no horror yeah I
do hope that there is some worries I'm
sure some good character modes I mean
what gives me faith is that their
earlier movie was more of a character
piece it was less you know effects and
stuff like that
before we wrap this video up John I
think we should give a page from the day
shout-out to a beautiful woman named
Jenna Randolph you see way back when a
couple years ago she was the one who was
very adamant about us doing a trailer
reaction it Kingsman the Golden Circle
we did it we did it just for you just
only for you no one else
March 20th is her birthday I'm gonna
make sure to try to remember over the
next week that you have a birthday on
March 20th
either way happy early birthday you're
gonna be our age yay and I wanted to
show you out on Pet Sematary trailer
because she told me that her and her
father are gonna get a dog Oh perfect
timing for us to shout you out because
pet cemeteries about the love for
animals yeah no matter what no matter
what because cats and dogs don't live
for a very long time but if you have a
pet sematary you know and maybe you do
have a father-daughter kind of dynamic
the way how Jason Clark does with his
daughter in this movie maybe you did die
and you were buried and that's why you
go to you know comic conventions and for
anime the motivating factor and all
anime and convention fans have in common
include the facts of Nova and reanimated
Ohio Wisconsin for me and I yeah he's
sad toppers pizza congrats on the new
gig she's also an artist I hope that she
lets her art flourish a flounder but my
other we're gonna say flow anyway you
guys can subscribe to the reject nation
click that notification bell and check
us out on patreon